a Democratic member of Congress is
refusing to admit any wrongdoing tonight
after she was caught having an improper
sexual relationship with a 22 year old
member of her staff chief breaking news
correspondent Tracy Gallagher has the
latest on this breaking story
Tracy hey Tucker Democratic congressman
when Katie Hill is clearly viewed as a
rising star of the party's new
progressive wing she initially got
glowing media coverage and was quickly
brought into the party's leadership then
news broke about her being in a
so-called throuple a relationship with
her now estranged husband Kenny Heslop
and a 22 year old unidentified female
staffer red state obtained both casual
and intimate pictures and critics said
the relationship which is now over was
inappropriate but Hill supporters say it
was between consenting adults now red
state has obtained text messages between
Haslip and the female staffer that
appear to call into question both the
power structure of the two-year
relationship and how the female staffer
felt it was abusive writing to Heslop
quote it was a dark time and you treated
me really poorly but I also stayed which
I have to own in response Heslop writes
quote don't take full responsibility for
staying with people that are abusing you
that is basically victim blaming and
none of it was your fault the staffer
also said she was afraid to push back
against Katie Hill for fear of losing
her partner and her job and now Kenny
Heslop says Katie Hill was an abusive
wife and accuses her of having an affair
with a male staffer Hill denies the new
affair and told POLITICO it was Heslop
who was abusive and that he's trying to
humiliate her by making vindictive
claims she also claims her opponents are
using a private matter for political
gain we reached out to have Katie hill
for further comment she has not gotten
back to us Tucker Wow
that's your average personal life looks
like not that we judge trace Gallagher
great to see you thank you you do